Today's video is about milking the Thorim cow.
It's an amazing piece of science. Before we start,
there are two or three things that I need to tell you so you can understand
quite how fantastic it is.
The first thing is that to treat cancer,
one can use highly radioactive atoms,
which are taken to the tumor by complexing them.
That's binding them to a protein that is attracted to the
tumor rather than the rest of the body.
The second point is that when a radioactive element
decays the products of the decay can be far more
radioactive than the original atom that decays you can
have theories.
That's not very radioactive decaying into something that's much more
radioactive.
And the third point just before we start is that when you have a
really radioactive atom,
even a nanogram that is 10 to the minus nine of a gram,
a thousand millionth of a gram has more than a hundred
times as many atoms as there are cells in your body.
So you need only a tiny amount of this highly radioactive material
to give a really big dose to the tumor.
So Brady was at the Oak Ridge national lab in Tennessee,
in United States.
And he was given a tour by Rose bowl,
who is an expert in the handling of these highly radioactive
elements.
Uh, we are at building 79 20.
This is the small hot cell room. We call them Ks.
This is where we do a lot of our medical isotope purification or the starting
part of it. And we'll sell you the rest of it later.
Some of the material we work with is very highly radioactive.
And so we need shielding to protect us from the dose that comes from that
material. So we work with it with remote handles.
This is Jay, who is doing the operation of the remote operators here.
We call them, um, manipulators.
And he's gonna show us the 3m two to nine cow that we use to milk
our medical isotopes from.
The guy who was doing it looked like a magician.
It was amazing how he could manipulate these robot arms.
Do you think you'd be good at it? I'm sure I'd be terrible.
Ethereum is dissolved in nitric acid. That's how we store it.
We don't want to take it back to the solid.
It becomes a very insoluble oxide.
So we keep it in liquid solution.
Cow is a sample of Thorim two to nine.
They thought it was just waste,
but then they suddenly realized this fantastic application and it's
called the cow because it keeps on giving more
and more active Liam,
just in the same way that a cow keeps on giving milk.
But the difference is you don't have to feed the Ethereum,
but you do have to feed the cow.
Yeah, this is all material, but at the time that it was me,
we didn't have a medical isotope application.
So this was something that would have been thrown away as waste material that we
were able to go and recover. Something very useful out of it.
Chemistry or perhaps the physics behind it is the Storium two
29 gives out an alpha particle,
which has mass four and contains two protons.
So you go to elements to the left, to radium,
and then the radium gives out to beat apart. Cool, that's an electron.
And it goes one element to the right and you get to 10 Liam,
two to five.
The first stage of the milking is to remove the Thorim from
solution so that you can then process the actinium.
And they do this with a resin solid acid,
which is something like this material here.
This is also a solid acid,
essentially tiny pellets of polystyrene,
which have been treated. So they have acid groups on it.
He pulled that rack out off.
You notice it was up against the wall to start with our 3m.
We run it through that column to separate it from the actinium.
That's an anti an exchange column.
It has a glass frit on the top that holds the resin down for when we dump water
on top, it doesn't disturb the resin bed. And, um,
it's stored with water on it right now until we go to do the next run,
the next separation run.
No, not in that column. In fact, we keep our, uh,
radioactive material off of the column between runs because it,
the radiation will restore the residence.
So now they have a solution which contains actinium and some
radium,
they put it through series of other columns to purify it with
raisins and they adjust the acidity of the solution. So that first,
all the radium is removed and eventually all they're left with is pure
actinium. Yeah.
And today we're packaging it in small glass vials in order to
ship it to the customer. So over on this next place here,
this is where they're doing the evaporation of the material.
They are only going to produce a sample of about a nanogram and
nanogram is such a small amount of material that you can't actually see it.
The problem is that whoever's going to buy it needs to know where it is.
So they use a bottle which has a V-shaped bottom
conical, bottom. So as you concentrate the liquid,
it goes right down to the bottom.
Try to evaporate it down in the V part, the very bottom,
because the customers usually dissolve this up in
about 100 or 200 microliters of solution,
which is about two to three drops.
They evaporated and you'd get the bottle.
And right at the bottom is a tiny bit of actinium. So the question is,
how do they know if they've got a new there?
And they have an extraordinarily cunning piece of kit,
which they call the gamma Ray camera,
which measures some of the gamma rays that are given out
by the actinium when it decays.
Gotcha.
Right? It's like light beam or photon of light,
but very short wavelengths. So we'll go through a lot of materials,
including through the shielding, the front of the box.
Another way you can see the element is that as it decays,
it actually gives out a glow of blue light.
The glow is pretty weak. So if you want to photograph it,
you have to switch out all the lights and do a long exposure.
Uh, they're bagging out the dry side. Um, actinium two 25.
So we took it to complete dryness in those glass vials.
So she'll work it all the way down to the bottom of the bag.
And then there'll run a heat seal across there.
The plastic is melted there into a band
[inaudible].
I should say they sell the bottle for a thousand dollars.
Just wait a moment.
A thousand dollars for 1000th of a microgram
means that you would have to pay a thousand million
dollars for a gram of this material. Of course,
you couldn't make a gram of this material and it would be so radioactive
that nobody could handle it,
but that just gives you an idea of the sort of price of this
material.
Use it to make medications. And so the medicine, this is actually,
they tell me is one of the less expensive ingredients necessarily in the
final medicine. Once they get it made,
we're very motivated by the fact the application.
Everybody knows somebody who's had cancer or some family member that has cancer
and is dealing with that.
So we're very excited to be able to work with something that we know
gets immediate application. You know,
a lot of the research that we do down the road, it might develop into something,
but ours,
it goes out weekly for patients to be treated.
So it's very nice being that closely connected with them.
[Inaudible].